[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we fear
everyone we we do fear everyone I am
scared fear everyone get these shirts in
October you got to follow our Instagram
to know when we're launching them it
means fear everyone right or it doesn't
mean I am afraid of everybody you said
it a couple times it's actually wrong
the grammar is wrong the way it's
written is wrong so it's like if this
was a it's like all right if this was a
sentence right this is supposed to be up
here this is supposed to be down here
everywhere here there's supposed to be
two more there's supposed to be two more
characters yeah okay so what's it say it
says um
o but it's supposed to be n o n is not
afraid of n is like the anti it just
sounds so cool though it sounds cool
even when it's wrong yeah I like that so
what's the should say
though
everyone uh I know I'm I'm afraid
everyone got OS everyone so it is yod to
speak everyone I'm
afraid afraid of everyone
put yeah oh that's so great fear fear
yeah I'm afraid I'm afraid it just
doesn't actually make real sense no and
it's wrong that's why it's
like yeah well hey we got here because
we [__] hit some goals and so today's
conversation topic is uh what personal
goals do you guys currently have right
now personal goals personal goals we
know you just [__] dominated your two
swords wielding bodybuilding competition
sir but now I'm guessing you're already
immediately on to your next goal what's
a personal goal that we all have moving
forward right now I'm working on um
buying existing
businesses so like up until now all of
my experience has been startups like
creating something from scratch you know
JK like the food groups all these
different projects maybe like one-offs
like creating a product um and a lot of
these things it takes a lot of time
money and sometimes you don't get
anything paid like from doing it right
and then I got
into thinking about there's a lot of
businesses out there especially with
Boomers retiring there's business cuz in
my mind I thought all businesses that
were going for sale were broken and it
sucks that's why they're going for sale
cuz why would anybody in their right
mind let go of something good but then I
realized there's a lot of people that
want to retire there's nothing wrong
with the business but they want to
retire uh but they their kids don't want
the business you know and then there's
there's like as time progressed my I
realized there was so much more to it
than just like if a business is for sale
doesn't mean that it's it's a piece of
[__] there's solid businesses out there
and then the plus part is it's already
bringing in
income so you don't have to start from
scratch where you dump all this money
and get a bunch of investors and just
hope that it makes money right it's
already a viable business and what you
got to do is go in and you can make
improvements with the income that's
already coming in so um yeah me and my
buddy were already in talks of looking
at different companies and yeah it's
kind of a fun next level I guess like
taking on everything that I learned
building YouTube all this stuff J be and
then putting it all together and it's
really exciting yeah yeah can you
disclose any uh not yet not yet no but
I'm I I'll tell you guys after this deal
is solid but it takes a long time bro
like the whole deal making process it's
like at least 6 months and I was just
like wow
I why can't I do this in like a week I
mean Buy in like a day you know like
[__]
yeah nice yep hey good luck man thank
you thank
you the real reason is I'm just trying
to find ways to sponsor this channel so
I'll probably like get all my other
businesses to just sponsor it so we'll
be doing ad reads for our own comp
that's SM don't give yourself discounts
right
yeah this video is brought to you by me
chubby personal goals huh Steven we got
two months to make it baby this is
it we're going into the run right now
the uh the crypto bull Run's about to
start go it's going to start why why
only two months well it's really just
about taking this dip seriously and most
people and most people aren't people are
sleeping right now on the market there
like volumes have been have been dried
up for a while now you just got the most
bullish news like ever about how every
single huge firm wants to open a a
Bitcoin ETF now all these huge firms are
saying they wanted uh an ethereum ETF
crypto is about to explode nobody's even
really talking about it everyone's sore
sleeping in fact people in my fantasy
football group who I've known for a
decade or like you're St that crypto
thing is so dead I'm like dude you guys
don't even know $1.5 trillion market cap
you think it's dead it's just going to
keep growing keep sleep walking bro but
you're going to be a fomo in [__] and
not a a badass [__] who was who was
buying up the bottom and I've been
hoovering the bottom for [__] what
how long have I hoovering how long I've
been doing it for like 20 months what 20
months right now yeah and I've been
taking it seriously that's that bottom
exactly but that's how you do it you
have to take it seriously and so you
know taking this dip seriously for the
next two months is really what I'm I'm
the most focused on I also you know want
to do um well I had a couple of goals
from the last one right that I'm going
to take into this run which is like
start spin up an ethereum node right so
that I'm I have my own validator that
like like I can I can host and then you
know people put their ethereum on my
validator and then we can split up the
fees and [__] like that so that'll be
really fun um and then I want to
um basically crush the run and then as
as I'm going through the Run cash out
way more into Bitcoin and ethereum as I
beat them in the ratio so that's what I
do every run and so it's all about
making sure that the next 2 months I
really land I nail this end of the year
and then I can kind of chill lot next
year as the Run starts so yeah I'm
excited about it also work on something
I can't really talk about CU I don't
like to do that but I'm excited about it
um but I don't like to do I don't like
to be YouTube I'm doing a secret project
and [__] I'm just yeah I'm working on
I'm working on something that I that I I
find very fun so is in the creative
realm yeah in the Creative Real on on
the side yeah yeah is it something
you've done before I've talked to you
guys about it off camera got you oh okay
yeah so we'll see what happens waet very
cool [__] yeah
baby dip make sure you're taking the
next two months really seriously
honestly I'm buy
lunting Bitcoin nice and woo of course
every month every month love it love it
taking it seriously here is everything
I'm about to get into position right now
dude I already got a usdc ready to go oh
yeah we set you up last time good
lunchtime purchase colen got in I know
yeah and I need to hop on board too I've
been
dcing dcing what little stuff here and
there Disney California Adventure talk
about it butt
biomes butt biom a [__] joke is that
is this what are your goals dude uh I'm
kind of in a place now where I'm trying
to figure out if I want to do more
inperson stuff or more online stuff
online cuz I'm realizing that like
so like the past two weeks my clients
were all like out of town I guess and I
guess it's like the most the last couple
weeks of August is like the most
requested uh PTO time like across the
board so like all my clients were out of
town so I kind of had like two weeks to
chill out a little bit and it was kind
of cool and being home was really cool
and spending time and you know I really
like that aspect but I also really like
working with people in the gym all day
too so I think I need to figure out
where I'm going to spend more of my time
too and I think it is more on the online
side but um I think I need to just
commit more a one cuz I think I try to
serve two masters and then I'm
like you know something gives you know
it was something and I want to have more
time at home so I think the online stuff
is looks a little bit more appetizing so
just learning how to do more of that
stuff learning how to do like
advertisements online and all that stuff
learning how to do online business a
little bit more so that's the fun part
for me that's a personal what online
kind of what online kind of stuff just
online coaching online fitness coaching
you know well you could open up your
service to everybody that's watching now
when it's online and people that
actually like you they'll be like maybe
you can make me laugh while I work out
no no I I have I have like a a client
roster online but it's just more of like
all right am I going to go a lot more of
those in person or a lot more of those
like online so that's like I think the
place that I'm in right now so I I just
have to make a decision I think and I
think it's online am I right yep I got
balance I got 5050 or like a 752 maybe
like a 7030 type of deal more online and
then because the onl online stuff takes
a lot of time to do too like I thought I
could do both at the same time but I'm
learning that if I really want to make
the income that I want online or just in
general I have to spend a lot more time
and it'll take me out of the gym what
about like less personalized and more
like programmatic online stuff where
it's not it's like pre-recorded like
programs you yeah no definit I think
that is an Avenue for sure
but yeah I think you should do online
only fans and personal training can you
think oh you do personal training only
fans where they come and then they can
buy a service and you're just naked
showing them how to do all the moves
like this and I have a new I have a
sweet new tattoo so it's like it's even
more kind of hard yeah I'm pretty hardc
oh yeah I'm probably going to take this
tattoo in the wild too and get a video
of Asian people reacting to it you
should go Little Tokyo yeah what do you
think of my what do you think of my my
tattoo that's going to be fun is that
the passion project no that's just an
idea that I had that I got to
do but I'm going to treat it like hard
yeah yeah yeah like how do you think my
tough ass tattoo it's hard as [__] isn't
it or a bandana hard as [__] or no jean
jacket no sleeves come on so yeah that's
that's the personal goal for me right
now is get more time for my family and
my kids you
know cuz they're growing up so fast so
fast dude you know cuz your kids age by
seven years every
year so I'm I'm on borrowed time with
these little pups dude even even seeing
you do uh more of the
online uh just those those fight videos
and stuff like that you're doing that we
talked about last time and then seeing
people Us Media and then seeing people
in the comments being like yo you're
like a real influencer now yeah I don't
like that I don't know but but that like
feeds into the idea of like online
tutorial program no for sure yeah it
does so well it's just weird when you're
yeah I don't know it's just a different
different lens I guess that it's weird
cuz you hate yourself so much yeah
that's what it really is but then you're
the kind of guy but you're the kind of
guy who likes it you dislike
something he just said that outside by
the way about his tattoo because I know
that like my [__] ass brain is saying
this is stupid this is dumb like you
want to poo poo everything and I know
that's not the correct thing to do so I
know that at least if I poo poo this
then I'm on the right track does that
make sense nope what the hell trying to
say I don't know what the hell you're
trying to say no because I know this is
this is nonsense I don't want to be here
you know that I know that oh I need to
go against my programming and do more of
that oh like doing more of the things
that you said you're not supposed to be
doing because that's where the growth
happens well my mind says poo poo
against male anal sex should I do that
more for me yes that see that made sense
yeah yeah yeah take notes from be more
uncomfortable
yeah what about you Ryan what kind of
personal goals do you sometimes after
Nick talks I think I know him
less is that a weird phenomenon it's
stunning well I'll tell you right now
what do you want to know at least he's
not deflecting that much anymore yeah
he's just boring us today I just know
that when I talk I put myself I bore
myself and I know that everyone else is
here bored so I'm like all right dude
let's hurry this up is this good
content not really before I used to want
to grab his ears and pull it apart and
say say something already cuz you're
saying words but nothing I'm just going
to start sending you uncut clips of
yourself back at you oh that's don't do
that that's the next good Ryan bit
against you want to assist my Suicide do
that dude my actual uh goal that's been
on my mind honestly is
to uh basically to
propose can you say that doesn't she
watch the show she doesn't watch the
show she doesn't no none of our wi start
going on her page it's not going to be
that I mean it so she finds out
something that's pretty obvious I mean
it's it's a but but the thing is that uh
one thing she doesn't know is that like
and this will come out probably when
we're married for six years true that's
a good point one thing she doesn't know
is like uh like I haven't done it yet
because I'm trying to get in the right
position for it which means like I want
to ask both of her parents individually
and then um to go to Australia to do it
yeah yeah but but I'll be there in a few
months and then that's where I'm when
I'm going to ask her mom are you going
there without her no I'm not so how you
going to pull him to the side I'll
figure it out you're you're not going to
be like here's a note I'm I going to
slip a note why do you have to ask your
mom I think I I just want to do it that
yeah is that even traditional heard
never owns her I already asked her I
already asked her dad wow what did he
say and he said no so he's got to ask
the mom when he was here he was visiting
like a couple months back and then um it
was funny because like obviously we were
all together most of the time and then
we went to go get coffee real quick and
then smack went to the bathroom and was
like all right we only got like a minute
here so I started talking to was he like
what the [__] yeah I was like and I I
basically like asked him right there and
then he like started crying and stuff it
was like dope and then smack he started
crying yeah and then smack got gets out
the bathroom he's like oh all right
well funny man it was a good moment yeah
it was it was a dope ass
moment share this with smack if this
comes out chill maybe don't but yeah you
[__] be chill you ass Buy the T-shirt
she'll find out obviously naturally I
guess but then I want to individually
have that same uh moment with their mom
we see her share this video with her mom
and once that's like squared off then
then that's when that today's video is
brought to you by
Lumi have you ever said to yourself
maybe I should start wearing deodorant
if you're out there and you're a normal
person and you do wear deodorant have
you ever told yourself maybe I should
stop wearing things that have harmful
metals and chemicals that can destroy me
like aluminum parabens all those things
well good thing Lumi is here to give you
some beautiful alternatives for your
body yeah it's invented by OBGYN lady so
she treats the labias and she made
something that works on the laas so if
it works on the labas it works on
everything else because that's one of
the most sensitive skins in the whole
wide universe yeah if it's not going to
destroy the puss puss then it won't
destroy you and it has beautiful
smelling M this one is orange I like it
so much yeah this one is clean Tangerine
mm and this one is cool cucumber and
everything is ph balanced perfectly yep
so if you want to smell fresh and use
something wonderful for your whole
entire body from head to the bottom of
your toenails go ahead and get yourself
some Lumi okay so the Lumi starter pack
right here is perfect for new customers
comes with the solisti deodorant cream
tube deodorant and two free products of
your choice like the mini body wash and
the deodorant wipes and free shipping oh
what free shipping that's so cool free
man as a special offer for our listeners
new customers get $5 off our Lumi
starter pack with code OTR at lumipod
docomo to lumipod
docomo thank you very much ding dong you
know what's going to suck when you
propose and just blow everyone out of
the [__] water and guys just
don't even want to propose anymore you
good thing you guys are all married
already I I agree yeah I don't want to
do nothing like super you have the the
place in mind of where you're going to
do the actual proposal I have a I have
an idea of part of what I want to do but
I also don't want to make it so heady
like I don't I want it to be as like I
guess like natural and yes you want to
make too like orchestrated and logical
TR I don't want to make it seem like I'm
doing it for me you know what I mean I
just wanted to be like hey this is the
real [__] that's smart I want to go
through the he's the groom that just has
the camera on him the whole time the
whole time you don't even know the
bitch's name you don't barely see the
[__] it's all about the to his life cuz
I think when like when when I was like
asking to be her like boyfriend that was
different because it was like I wanted
to like show her how much I care but
it's like we already know that now so
now it's like I just want to go through
the proper uh channels and just like due
diligence that's it
that's it I don't want to like I don't
want to be all [__] a cake with
nothing but frosting you know what I
mean if you think about it though that's
kind of The Proposal is like when you
guys got together and then you cuz like
we do things so differently now cuz like
people didn't move in before they got
married yeah and then they weren't
[__] and like enjoying each other for
years like a married
couple before getting married so you got
to actually live a practice marriage
without the paperwork yeah yeah yeah and
now you're just kind of like it's been
working how many years has it been it's
been almost 8 years wow so you're
practically married have built a
business together we're just like super
secure with each other and it's like we
both have the same like view about like
you know we're not trying to rush we're
also you know so why did you wait 8
years for good
taxes we didn't really mean to wait 8
years it was just so like Breezy that it
never was like a a thing that we ever
felt like we had to do and uh and if
it's it's one of those things like if we
never did it it would also probably be
okay but I think we both want that life
you know you want that tax break I mean
we don't even give a [__] about that
really that's really really I want the
tax breaks for you guys all right I'll
get the tax break I want JK to move to
Nevada how about that I want
Nevada he's making an exodus that's what
I'm saying I know he's like that's like
another long-term plan that we we have
is to at least like set ourselves up to
where Nevada is a place that we can go
yeah I'll be there but never there watch
out for the mosquitoes watch out for the
mosquitoes and the flashs watch out for
the lake river the lak river yeah that's
my that's my sh that's that's sweet wow
dude that's a big one a big Life Update
that's [__]
crazy did everybody go Bart did you go
not
really needs to go again let me just
think about this let me write it out
first did you figure out if you want to
go online or
offline had me gripped there's no B I
was on the edge of my seat he's like I
think I'm going 7030 maybe 65 25 yeah
yeah I just like being boring I think I
just like
being I wish that was my life update
it's my life
dude it's boring but it's my life
Bart um my personal goal he just
finished a big one yeah dude what's next
well I guess there's like there's still
like simultaneous cuz there's like stuff
that you personally want to do things
that are like in the relationship or
financial or whatever I think now like
my next big goal is probably like
building like our home home so you know
like the last couple of years we've been
moving quite a bit cuz it's your forever
home for the fourth time yeah so now
it's like really making sure this one's
a forever home so that we can get the
next forever no it's I think we really
like where we live um and we have a
really good routine um taica is doing
really good in school and he loves all
his friends like he just had his uh uh
sixth year birthday and it was cool to
see like like the little you know like
when you live in a new place you kind of
don't really have a community just yet
and then as parents I feel like you just
kind of work and it's you're kind of
community your community is either the
immediate physical neighbors or uh the
community that your kids are involved in
so now we we booked like a little like
trampoline park thing for his birthday
and it was cool to see like kids from
Jiu-Jitsu there kids from his uh school
there kids from even his some of like
the ones he kept in contact from his
last school and just to kind of see all
of that be together and some of his
neighbors that go to different schools
and then like me envisioning oh these
kids are all going to grow up together
like six seven eight nine and just kind
of seeing like um what that's going to
be like in the next five 10 years and
that makes me feel like really good
because like growing up I moved a lot
too actually because I got I kept
getting kicked out of a lot of schools
so I never felt like I had Roots
anywhere so like I would meet people
like like my friend silent Mike who's
like oh yeah this is my friend my best
friend since second grade I'm like dude
I wish I had that I never really like
Joe's the longest friend I've ever had
but I made friends with him in my adult
life and I just wish I had that
stability as a kid so being able to put
ourselves in a position to give him that
kind of stability where once he gets a
little bit older he can invite his
friends to come over and swim at my pool
or like you want to have a sleepover
just kind of like that kind of like
childhood that I've always wanted I
never had is like our main goal so
you're like a stage pageant mom but like
pageant dad for your son pageant Dad
how's so like you're making him do it
like he doesn't want to do it you're
leaving by KY through your son oh I see
I see I see I was like yeah I'm like
what am I signing a he's like I don't
have friends yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so that's that's that's kind
of the goal and so like even us uh
building our house out to be that way
yeah like we're we're trying to plan
like a little jungle gym in the side and
then you know like having the dogs run
around and swim and stuff like just
trying to make the the home feel as
homey and comfortable as possible for
friends family whoever to come and stay
over is like is like the goal yeah dude
you're a real [__] dad I know dude
you're the dest man planet espe with
those two tattoos
bro
dude I I like I I really enjoy being a
dad and I enjoy seeing like um him grow
up and then also like I can it's like
and you feel your personal growth too
cuz then like he's uh an extension of
you right so there's personality traits
that you don't like about yourself but
they have it and they do it and then you
have the first initial urge what is what
my dad did and then you're like but that
didn't work you know so like so as you
raise them you have the most craziest
growth too and then like there's times
I'm just like this with ta like man
you're [__] cool dude you know that
he's like yep and then I'm like just
like really cool moments that you get to
create that you felt like since you
didn't get were out of bounds but you
make your bounds yeah I feel the same
way about my dogs bro yeah swear to God
cuz like I want to yell at them but I
know it's it's not their fault it's my
fault I'm the one that dropped the ball
so I have to blame myself so you know
what I mean and it's you know they're
what about the bite your shoes I
shouldn't have put the shoes there I put
them in a situation to fail right cuz
they go like this with the shoe yeah
it's on me and I feel like I got to I
want to hit them but I can't did they
say if they want you to go online or
offline
more they want me they want me online so
I can stop them from eating their own
[__]
Ryan we're out we're
out we need Anthony n dude we're out of
time [__] you what it's just all you
then we got to clap because n just
hijacked moment okay I'm py back it's
not hijack a beautiful moment too it was
like one of the sweetest things I've
heard and also the saddest things I've
heard cuz he's like I didn't get that
from my dad but I have to make this with
my son and [__] I'm like damn that's
really sad and then Nick's [__]
ripping him about the
dog and he calls him a pageant Dad yeah
dude but I guess pageant dad's a great
line we're going have to start using
that it's just I relate that's all let's
see that [__] smile
[__]
Anthony Lee Anthony Lee oh okay um I
would like to become a dad
oh let's go online or offline dude are
you cre you going to start cream
ping dude Joe's H Jesus have you started
or not yet not yet woo wow but I am I am
going on a honeymoon in October you know
where we to we too Maui we got Bali oh
and are you leaving the condoms at home
hell yeah baby I'm not bringing any oh
damn and I heard Balan condoms tend to
rip pant
condoms in Indonesia that's word on the
street word on the street is lot of
pregnancies happening B that that her
mom definitely watches our show so I'm
going to keep that at a more romantic
level okay dude it's too late for like
being careful with that careful boys
okay uh hi Mom and then uh d we're
becoming adults huh kind of bunch of
dads we're adulting in here aren't we we
all got this [__] tattoo yeah three
dads keep young man dude we're going to
be like 40y olds like soon you look like
so you guys like you guys have talked
about it like like hey I'm going [__]
in you like start [__] your box I
think he said we definitely talked about
it okay I think I think a lot of
conversations help with the mental
preparation you know like you just need
to constant it's been like
even since like last year you know what
I mean just like constantly talking
about it just to remind ourselves that
are we serious even for myself like
jokingly being confident hey D I'm going
to [__] have like 12 kids I want an
army but even though obviously I don't
why that's a lot that's what I'm saying
obviously oh that's
cool I idea of like you know like almost
speaking sarcastically past a threshold
to like kind of like fall back to
understand where you really are be
comfortable with it you know um seeing
where both people are at and how you
guys even react to each other is like
crazy IDE you ever talk about
names uh we do but it's like less than
the amount that we talk about being uh
almost grounded and realistic at the
idea of always saying like I would like
to try never being like I want kids
being like I would like to try to have
kids just like having seen so many other
friends go through cuz you keep yourself
one in your front
pocket dude I think about that [__] too
kills the sperm yeah there it is but
just a of like how many people have gone
through like miscarriages or like have
tried and like failed and stuff and just
being like I don't want to Psy myself
out to think it's a guarantee just
because you like [__] cream pie you
know what I mean it's like you got to
get some people don't have kids for like
seven years and then all of a sudden
four of them fly
out it's crazy fly out they look like
pugs you know um but yeah just like just
having conversations around the whole
realm but at the same time trying to
ground yourself to like the
practicalities like of life so it's it's
it's a trip but it's a personal goal if
that's a goal if it's weird call it a
goal the practicalities of Life are more
practical in Nevada though I was just
about to say that right out of my mouth
[__] having a kid in Nevada has a
certain ring to it yeah it does but none
of my none of our parents are there so
and there's less of people's peees
getting chopped off that's exactly it is
pretty
interesting I I think I would like to
check the studies on that actually you
don't have to have Gavin Newsome as
Governor while you're giving birth
that's
huge it's a big du um I think you guys
know I uh getting to a place of personal
fitness is a personal goal of mine yeah
dude look how sex you are dude look how
[__] hot you are not yet not yet but
the thing that [__] really stuck to
me still like months ago when I was
talking to you about it and like not
having certain like goals whether it be
like physicality or Aesthetics but like
making it a lifestyle you know what I
mean like a part of your identity where
you it's so ingrained in your lifestyle
this is what you do that it's Clockwork
you don't think about it as like you're
trying to do it cuz you're trying to hit
a certain goal or whatnot you know and
even for like the last 3 months since I
started you know it's just been about I
have no idea how I'm supposed to look
you know what I mean but just like
learning about it and just being like
stay consistent let this be a part of
your life and your identity and it's
helped out a lot versus trying to just
you know my younger versions of myself
being like I want to lose this much
weight or I want to gain this much mass
or I want to blah blah blah like that's
totally different from just like I want
to stay consistent you know it's just
what you do yeah so it's been it's been
helpful it's been exciting it's been fun
obviously there's like you know really
inspiring guys in this room that keep me
motivated you got it exactly any day um
but that that's that's a fun thing but I
think that's also in line with the idea
of wanting to be healthier for myself
cuz I'm consistently [__] sick for
some random reason uh and then also also
trying to have like a kid too right
Catch Co 74 times yeah a record so the
idea of like wanting to like create life
but needing to be healthy
first he's probably woring a mask more
than any was
guaranteed